what's your reaction to Boris Johnson
resigning and the way in which he's done
it
well it shows further contempt for
Parliament doesn't it as you as you've
just read out from the um the Privileges
committee uh I mean it is a very
extraordinary moment in our history not
only has this uh man been
ousted from Downing Street
um having won a general election only
two years previously
um he's also now be as I understand it
from what Boris Johnson himself has said
the Privileges committee were about to
recommend to the house that he be
suspended for a substantial period which
might lead to a by-election because he
had lied to Parliament and done so
repeatedly and culpably and that is a
very extraordinary moment for us um it's
very difficult to bring a minister to
book for lying to Parliament we found
this with other ministers as well
recently including Savannah Braverman
and Richie sunac
um but this is so this is an
extraordinary moment and of course he's
brought all of this down upon his own
head
um by refusing to correct the record by
repeatedly denying that there are events
that happened which he was actually
present at so yes it is a very
extraordinary moment and the the one
thing I think he was probably hoping was
that the report would just out die well
that's not right what will happen is
that that um I'm not on the committee
but I'm guessing that what the committee
will do as well as you said they will
meet on Monday they'll complete their
report and and they may for all I know
and conclude uh to add another paragraph
which says that he's acted in complete
contempt of Parliament that report will
then go to the House of Commons and the
whole house will vote on it
um some people have said that he's been
terribly Brave uh Boris Johnson I see it
quite the reverse he's been so cowardly
that he's not prepared to face the music
in the House of Commons where he has a
66-seat majority or for that matter
excuse me
or for that matter in his constituency
in Uxbridge I think he's a coward
and he does maintain his innocence as
you say he vigorously defends himself
says the committee hasn't produced a
shred of evidence and some of the
language towards the committee is is
pretty strong from him isn't it that he
calls it a Witch Hunt a kangaroo court
he talks about the report being riddled
with inaccuracies wreaking of prejudice
he talks about an absurd and unjust
process and he uh and a political hit
job as well and criticism in particular
for its chair Harriet Harman we've had
this response from the Privileges
committee what do you sense the mood
will be amongst them
oh I don't know but I know what the
feeling is will be about in Parliament
and I presume this is why Boris Johnson
decided to run for the hills rather than
let the report go to the whole House of
Commons
um which is that he clearly holds
parliament in contempt and I think
um the feeling is entirely Mutual uh
this is the this is the end of his
political career he's not going anywhere
after this and all this talk of him
possibly coming back in another seat and
you know waiting in a in the sidelines
waiting for the conservatives to lose
the next general election I'm afraid I
think that that's all just rather silly